are we live are we alive
for sure for real can they see us i
think so should i pull my pants up
are you ready wendy open the pod bay
doors how did you just [ __ ]
was that purple rain we got oh that was
genius
is the water ready yes lisa shall we
begin
yes lisa welcome to fat man beyond man
i'm kevin smith i'm mark bernard if you
can't tell folks i'm super [ __ ] dirty
before we start he's like buddy i think
you might have to drive tonight
i did i was like you might have to drive
i'm really
[ __ ] baked um yeah i'm pretty damn
big too
uh but not in any and that's not
bragging kids don't be like
me it's not bragging it's
but it's just normally i'm not and then
i smoked some more
when i got here so i'm really [ __ ]
i'm wait i'm feeling great did you just
say
normally i'm not i don't get high
anymore
you know you know i'm always blazed i
guess but i don't really get
high but like i am [ __ ] feeling high
[Laughter]
you're gonna get some victor garber [ __ ]
out of him
somebody pointed out on twitter um
he they said hey he was also an alias uh
i waited a week to say
you're right yes he is
you were right i'm gonna fight that
isn't that nice to hear
from someone on twitter in the real
world i mean that's the opposite effect
of twitter
generally some people be like you're
wrong but instead here i am going like
oh my god you're right
well done uh garber update oh [ __ ]
stand by kids we got a garber update
this uh i uh i
emailed his publicist
keep us in the two-shot what yeah i
tracked down his publicist and i was
like hey man
all right now give him a single give
mark a single he's going deep what yeah
i went on [ __ ] imdb
pro for which i apparently have an
account to
found his representatives and i'm like
hey dear bill
i think his name was like hey listen i
co-host this podcast with kevin smith
and
we had a really good time talking about
trying to get victor garbo on the show
it'd be really great if he's available
if he wanted to swing through and skype
into the podcast
signal silence so far but the ask is out
i'm about to get turned down twice by
victor garber
very few people could make that claim um
no response
uh i just lo today is when i did it so i
didn't quite expect one but
just the the victor garber story is not
entirely over
look at that kids keep hope alive we may
indeed talk to victor garber
let's start laying money on this
i'll put i'll put ten thousand dollars
on him like never calling back no maybe
calling back but being like
um you know normally we don't we just
don't respond
if we don't want to do something but in
this case i'm going out of my way to
tell you
victor's not busy but no tell your
[ __ ] friend that
tell him he can't get around me he can't
circumvent
garber [ __ ] pr and i think public
relations
once uh once garber's personal pr shoots
us down
uh then then we there's another way in
there's another way in man there's
warner brothers man there's [ __ ] like
let's go to warner brothers tv pr
and say listen you got to have some
legends of tomorrow [ __ ] juicy juice
right you still still on the show did he
die he's on the show
that's your way in the show he's off but
he was just i thought you had a plan
oh i'll tell you we got somebody else
that's my last
[ __ ] rip cord [ __ ] my third
parachute the one i hang
slung between my nuts is
i reach out to down in the nut shack
down with the knife
i pull that cord i reach out to ben and
be like
you know him he was an argo i don't want
you ben
i want victor [ __ ] garbage i think
ben would be like oh my god that's the
call i've always dreaded he wants me to
be on his podcast and i'm like
can you get me victor garber i think
matt would be like oh [ __ ] up that god
thank god yeah [ __ ] yeah i'll get you
victor garber um
that would be my last resort i i would
like ben to like
[ __ ] trick him into it by giving him
the wrong skype address like you know
just dial into this one and suddenly
i guarantee you would be like click
that's not been a good show it would be
great
make i'm so [ __ ] it's like i find it
sweet that you went out of your way and
asked
you know it's because i heard and and
like like that's
it's adorable i i i rarely give you any
presents
and i felt like this was a gift that i
could give to you
the gift of garber the gift of garber
kids
in this horrible quarantine please
remember it's always the season of
giving
the gift of garbage and mark
tried to give it this is like an o'henry
story
i didn't except i didn't try to get you
anything i mean it's our carver
anniversary
garber anniversary this is 11 years and
that's when you give garber
that's true that's true it's our garber
bursary
or anna garber um man that'd be
[ __ ] weird that's when we maybe
stopped the show
once you finally get him he's the white
whale he's our matt damon
we're done thanks everybody we're going
home so sweet who
who's been avoiding you your whole life
that i can reach out and try to find
just to repay no no one had to talk to
him
it's a tough gift to match man like my
circumstances are very specific
they really are i don't think i quite
have the uh the equivalent the
this person's been turning me down for
years would you take cash
i mean i know it's not as thoughtful as
what you did i got you a dunkin known as
a
certificate boom dunkin donuts i was
getting you tim hortons man
[ __ ] classy timmy ho timmy oh tea
little t-hoe for him
some tim bits and [ __ ] double doubles
if you will for our 12 canadian fans
indeed thanks for watching uh other than
smoking everything under the sun what
have you been up to
what have i been doing um i mean it's
early in the week right what day are we
thursday i mean it's the end of the week
boy time [ __ ] i [ __ ] know
something i did last night
[ __ ] two in the morning uh-oh give me
a close-up
oh we don't have that we can't do that
uh i fell asleep
early about nine o'clock nice sometimes
like a bottle particularly in the
quarantine you know i'll be honest i
would do that before the quarantine
um i fell asleep kind of early so
i woke up at like two in the morning and
i remembered
that i got an email earlier in the day
and a text reminder of the email that
they had sent
the animatic for episode four of our
netflix masters of the universe ooh
really
so you know i got up to take a leak and
then i was like [ __ ] sleep and i went
down to my office and i downloaded that
[ __ ]
god damn it it is a [ __ ] wonderful
show
it is such a great show uh and let me
tell you something
like the drawings are it's an animatic
there's spartan at best it's stick
figures like not even features and stuff
most cases just to represent
position and movement and stuff still
[ __ ] i watched an episode at two in
the morning i'm not even bullshitting
i watched it three times back to back
and this episode was 24 minutes it has
to come down by two minutes
and i think there's an easy two minutes
to pull and stuff because now you see
the pacing over here like we don't need
this scene as good as the scene is we
don't need this and let's
not make powerhouse animate this and
stuff plus
like each episode has to be a certain
amount of minutes and [ __ ] like that
so i watched this [ __ ] three times
back to back-to-back over an hour from
like two in the morning till like
3 30 and [ __ ] smoking and watching this
animatic
and i bawled my [ __ ] eyes out like
each time i watched it there's this
you know what happens this is episode
four
so you know yep holy [ __ ]
it is it's like i'm so proud of it
like i didn't write that episode that
was uh
tim wrote that episode just like episode
three which i've watched [ __ ]
to death mark wrote that episode and
there's this beautiful [ __ ] scene
like
you can't talk about it it's impossible
to talk about don't even but i'm telling
you like
it is a it's wonderful they're doing
such wonderful work the performances are
so great
and tonight we get to talk to somebody
who provides one of those performances
so um man oh man i got to do that and it
was a blast
um mine i had no notes for powerhouse
animation
my notes were more like we overwrote
this we gotta pull back
two minutes so that we don't sacrifice i
mean that's the thing the whole time we
were writing the episodes we were always
like
[ __ ] you know it's the words and the
[ __ ] oh they'll follow
fog and then you watch an episode where
they do a sequence where in the script
it was like
you know shadow demons surround them or
something like that
for example um what they gave
was far [ __ ] greater like they
created this animated sequence where
you're like
holy [ __ ] made me go back to the script
to be like
did we write that and we didn't and it
was one of the places where they were
like
hey it's a it's cartoon let's [ __ ]
let's go down nuts
and you're so thankful they did so what
a great partnership powerhouse killing
it man so i did that yesterday
what was i doing prior to that i've been
doing a lot of like streaming i feel
like
i've been doing a lot of stuff a lot of
cleaning
that's true i've been quarantined clean
cleaning my office and finding
old articles and [ __ ] i put up an
article from entertainment weekly
where we were on the same page from the
year of the panel and stuff
and they drew mark and his comic and
stuff i found
uh that battle star galactica card and
they're like come do an episode and [ __ ]
like that
um later on i found like the degrassi
movie script from like 2005 the outline
degrassi the movie for theatrical
relationship so i've been finding a lot
of
[ __ ] stuff and then you know it's all
fodder for the internet while i'm taking
pictures and throwing it up
but it's been a a beautiful walk down
memory lane like over at that kevin
smith club i started
on wake and bake the show that we do i
start
uh reading from the i found a journal
from like [ __ ] 1992.
oh emo kev yes and it's kev
right before my life breaks down into
two eras kev
bc and kev a.d kev before clerks
and a.d after dante so this is kev bc
man a caveman kevin [ __ ] at his most
pure
writing him his thoughts wow and
feelings and [ __ ] and his dreams about
the future
um it's [ __ ] nuts so it's like you
should get somebody to narrate
the kev journals you know what i'm
saying if alan rickman was still around
i would totally call in that favor and
be like alan can you be me
[Laughter]
can you channel i think you've been like
kevin nobody's that good of an actor
something drawl and wonderful i miss him
may 4th
he would have been [ __ ] wonderful in
the masters of the universe show oh
he'd have been great he used the hell
out of him man for something um but oh
my god
i sent mark like don't tell anybody but
a little clip
from his episode of a line that like i
just
loved that he wrote in his episode that
really just like
popped and somebody incredibly famous
wound up saying this very mark bernardin
specific line
so as i rewatched like episode three
over and over
i screen capped it you know [ __ ] shot
on my phone don't tell nobody
i was like dude don't [ __ ] tell
nobody because i want to on the show
um but it's such a like i mean you can
vouch for like how bare minimalist it is
oh yeah
no it's like it's it's you're right
stick figures with like
maybe shades and shadows of what might
be the rest of the figure
right and it's all black and white and
it's all very like it's
it's the blueprint for what's going to
be something awesome right
you got to see it in there and yet if
you know the scripts as we do
it's like oh my god like they're nailing
it and the fact that it's like the real
cast doing the voices and stuff
but magic oh just magic but i don't know
what the [ __ ] outs i've been up to
god all the days just bleed one into
another i had a pitch
yesterday that went very well good for
you
it was a zoom pitch um i can't talk
about it but it
is so in the wheelhouse of this [ __ ]
show
and uh covering it at some point yeah if
i
if i don't get the gig it's still a show
we'll be able to talk about because it's
a
mind bender um it shred my [ __ ]
consciousness because i was like
this is a [ __ ] thing holy [ __ ]
um and i got in maybe on the ground
floor and stuff
so that was yesterday um what else i've
been doing
man oh man like still like i'm an
intermittent fasting all the time
i don't know what have you been up to
[ __ ] me what about you you got a real
life
i got a real life i've been watching uh
re-watching for me but for my family
first time walking dead really yeah
cause
they had never watched they had never
watched and what spurred it on
um like we're living in the end times
pretty much let's get some tips from
this show it's like we've watched
everything else we might as well do this
now
um you really have watched everything
else if you're willing to go back having
seen wagon dead and restart it again but
it's well made right
it's i mean the first season it's six
episodes first season really really
sharp
yeah super sharp casting is great second
season kicks off with a bang we spent a
little bit too much time at herschel's
farm but whatever
the payoff for that is really strong but
uh i was inspired
by the the walking dead it was inspired
specifically by
john berenthal shane um
can't protect a wreck you don't know
rick you got to make the hard calls rick
you can't protect him rick
that's the best berenthol i can make it
like if berenthal can shave his own head
then i'm going to shave my own head
which i did today i cut my own hair
get out of here i did took a little
beard trimmer just [ __ ] went for it
how long did that take travis bickle
uh you know probably about 20 25 minutes
to get it right
and i don't think it's right but y'all
can't see very much of it
did you roll a camera on it i did not
roll again i [ __ ] taught you
nothing what a great extra for the show
it would have been you were like look
man
i decided to shave my head and here's
what it looks like
and cut to the tape yeah yeah um i
thought about jarring quarantine at one
point shaving my beard off and i was
like if i do
i am totally [ __ ] shooting that [ __ ]
and whatnot well because you've done
that when you were in [ __ ] yoga hoses
when you were the sausage nazi dude put
it up on lunch yeah
let's leave nazi off the resume
we got an all-ages show you did it um
yeah i don't know what i was thinking
some of that weed now i just do podcasts
and that makes everything a lot safer no
nazis
um the i love that movie i just
rewatched that movie because i'm working
on moose jaws
stand by it stand by and i know people
like you're [ __ ] crazy well
we'll see how crazy i am in 25 years i
think that's how long it's going to take
to really [ __ ]
have people be like i see it now i see
what he was that's what it matures
um one thing i've been doing is inside
editions which is a book company that
makes amazing
coffee table books thick ass like this
will [ __ ] brain you if you drop it
like out of a first floor window onto a
human being
type coffee table books about the [ __ ]
we love
so like a back to the future book or
[ __ ] this but like they do
books about genre and [ __ ] like that
books that you get at like
comic book store but on high-end
bookshelf like oh [ __ ] do i have
50 bucks for that book um
they're doing working on a project with
me that requires
uh me for two hours every day to go back
and
tell the story of my career oh my
yes so i've spent a long time over the
last two weeks like reliving
my entire career and uh chris prince
who's like conducting
the interview just keeps saying like
it's incredible how much [ __ ] you
remember from 26 years ago
and i'm like that's the story of my life
like that's where everything changed so
i really remember i got crisp memories
of all that
i don't remember what i did yesterday
but
[ __ ] god damn skippy remember what i did
to get here [ __ ]
what i did for love that's a little bit
of chorus line right there
for our three theater fans out there and
victor garber who's checking in for the
first time
yeah you know he was in sweeney todd the
only song from uh from
chorus line that i know okay tits and
ass tits
and uh which is legit a song i didn't
just make it up you guys
yeah crazy banquette perv bunch of
grandmothers just
[ __ ] signed off man i do remember
we're live you can't be like throwing
tits on
ass around we're gonna lose people on
the stream mark
listen i was 13. it spoke to me uh yeah
that song
speaks to a lot of us still i love
chorus line there's a great documentary
about the making of it
um marvin hamlisch a documentary about
marvin hamlisch he was the guy that
wrote the music and stuff
but they talked to like real people who
are actors and actresses trying to make
it on broadway and that's where all the
songs come from and
the people whose interviews they use
because they interviewed like hundreds
of people
the people whose interviews they used
guess who wound up in the cast
it's fascinating it's incredibly
democratic diplomatic process by which
one of the world's greatest broadway
musicals was made thank you for sticking
around for
hour two of fat man on broadway
i love that andrew lloyd webber did the
same thing for cats he would just
interview cats that he knew
and be like oh here's your story rum tum
tigger
tell me how you got to be here uh tell
me jellicle
and people like what does that mean he's
like that's what the cat said he told me
he's a jellico cat i don't know what
that is either
um yeah man [ __ ] there was a show
that like we lived on the east coast
could you avoid cats in your childhood
now and forever
thank you live at the winter garden
theater we are
programmed because we had like three
channels back in the day and
every one of them that was a local
affiliate would cut to a [ __ ] cats
commercial
who those winter garden people must have
had a lot of loot because they put that
commercial on so much that we remember
where it played well it was always
during the local news because you
couldn't like jump into actual nbc they
didn't have that kind of money
so it's like hi it's the channel 5 you
know evening news
brought to you by cats live with the
winter garden now and forever back again
and since your dad watched the [ __ ]
news all the time or your mom and [ __ ]
you were like cats now and forever
cats now and forever every day you heard
it [ __ ] drummed into your head
have you ever seen cats uh i saw the
movie but in life in real i mean i mean
actually
hey man look they're [ __ ] no have you
ever have you ever you never saw it
i've never been inside the winter garden
theater for the express purpose of
seeing cats well
[ __ ] how weird is like we know all
the information
but it didn't work no so i don't know if
is that marketing
is marketing like look we just have to
like it did work you [ __ ] pricks
because years later you're still
spouting our catchphrase
we were [ __ ] playing but is like
is marketing if i actually pay for the
thing or is marketing if i'm awareness
of the
yeah if you can transform awareness into
action is what is that market
so did they succeed as marketers when
they feel like they were more
brainwashing than marketing
it [ __ ] worked let me get you to say
this over and over again
i guarantee you one day you and i are
gonna be [ __ ] like woken like [ __ ]
sleeper agents like in the manchurian
candidate
and it's going to be like now and
forever winter garden and
i must kill the president angela
is going to be killed by or meryl streep
depending on which version of the
manchurian candidate you want
frank sinatra or denzel washington
do you have a preference between either
manchurian candidate between frank
sinatra and denzel
i wonder marc this is my get to know
mark perry
i don't know my friend very well so i
ask him questions like this i will say
this
denzel has had a frightening lack of top
10 singles
yes if i have to choose between those
two guys
i will say one of them has like an oscar
or two and the other one
has a lot of hitting records doesn't
frank sinatra have an oscar too whether
you know warranted or not or whatever
and i don't want this i mean look
to all our italian american friends
and everyone out there who loves
sanctuary somebody made him an offer he
couldn't refuse and that offer was
best picture i mean he's got an award
doesn't it i think he's
i don't think he might have gotten it
for manchurian candidate um i think he
was
nominated but i don't know if he ever
won but internet i'm sure you will
correct me
um with the truth of that statement uh
welcome to fat man on chairman as in the
chairman of the board
i like the uh the frank sinatra film
better the film is better
yeah john the demi made the other one
you did denzel washington
um and it had mel streep in it she
replaced angela lansbury
yeah the black and white one is probably
easier to take it is the the the color
went like it's
i get it like the story still holds up
but it just for some reason
the story really holds up now
very much so and we'll just leave it
there um
all right should we talk to chris what
time is it
let's do it we got a guest man we
started this guest thing it's been
working out man
people coming in on skype so much so
that when we're allowed to open up back
to the public here at the scum and
villainy cantina
right on hollywood boulevard hollywood
california a real place
where real entertainment is made for
real americans in the real world where
dreams are made of yeah
not right now but generally speaking
right now it's a nightmare town
but but a dream for traffic so
i got here in like three minutes from my
house
unheard of both ways we uh we got
uh live like skype happening and [ __ ]
like that
so uh we've done it a few times we had
jim leon
uh we had steve jepion and then we had
passenger passenger on and we were like
we should keep this [ __ ] going
so i reached out to one of my uh my
favorite people in the world one of my
most favorite [ __ ] individuals
on the planet very talented little boy
who i met while making one of those cw
shows
um that i'm such a fan of and stuff um
that little boy
grew up uh to be what does this say
sinatra wins the oscar you know what
andrew
you deserve to be well done he wanted
oscar from here to eternity
so before or after a manchurian
candidate
said before before or after herb waltz
wakes up with the horse head in his bed
yes but good on andrew for [ __ ]
diving into [ __ ]
andrew running technology over there jc
not giving a [ __ ] about what happened to
sinatra
he's not diving in there he's too busy
calling chris wood by
[ __ ] like telephone he's [ __ ]
writing a blog about how george lucas
got ignored
that year and [ __ ] the oscars and [ __ ]
like that um all right so back to the
what i was saying
uh one of my favorite people in the
world man lucky enough
uh if you're lucky enough to work with
the people you like and i met this kid
in on a set and um most people on sets
you know
not necessarily all likeable and stuff
like that
careful yeah um
like i said i'm really most people on
sets kid ain't just like people
he's [ __ ] lovable man like i i was
like god damn it
like i fell in love with him the way i
fell in love with ben affleck where i'm
like
you should be in everything [ __ ] you
should play fletch i still to this day i
think he'd be the perfect fletch
based on the gregory mcdonald books um
when
uh they we got lucky enough to work on
masters of the universe for mattel and
netflix
uh i you know there there was always
like we could probably get a big cast
for this and stuff
so i played very few
cards in terms of like well here's who i
think you could get and stuff like that
because
netflix mattel these cats putting up the
money they should tell us who they want
and stuff and
and teddy who's our netflix exec he
loves masters the universe so like
casting of course
with netflix uh the ability to draw
talent
it was going to be right up his alley
but one of the only names i put forward
in the process i was like i you know i
worked
with chris wood and he's so
good like he would be an excellent
prince adam and then
and and he-man as well of course but
like
yeah like i'm i'm can i put him on the
list
and they put him on the list and i you
know i thought that was going to be it
where they were like this kevin made a
suggestion and then we'll put it there
and then
it'll never happen and he he got the job
legit got the job and stuff mattel loved
him netflix loved him
boom he's our prince adam so here
tonight we got him
oh here tonight man making a little
chitchat
that's the sound of joy that's the sound
that means we're gonna talk to
a guest we get to open the door and
welcome to fat man
uh beyond uh he-man himself
ladies and gentlemen prince adam i give
you
chris wood oh my goodness
look at that intro look and look at that
look at that pretty ass
man look at how pretty he is
[Laughter]
somebody's been listening to the show
reminiscing about
this is actually as irish i was gonna
say
the first broadway show i ever saw kevin
was cats
was cats i totally forgot as we were
sitting here going nobody's gonna care
about us talking about broadway
there's one guy waiting to be on the
show who was like i'd love it if i was
having the time of my life
this was like batman broadway edition i
loved it
give us your full rundown of every
broadway show
that you've ever seen and when you say
broadway
do you mean i mean i mean i mean
broadway
like seeing an umbrella you're not just
live theater it's what you have
oh man that's that's where i that's
where i got my start that was my whole
the the stage was my whole thing um
uh you'd you'd have to sit here for like
three hours to hear all of the shows i
ever saw are you serious so wait it's
got a soft place in my heart still
you uh i remember when i was uh working
on um
supergirl um at one point
melissa was just like he was in sweeney
todd
and i was like what where are you when
you were in sweeney todd with victor
yeah yeah it's surprising he was in
sweeney todd
and he has worked on a victor garber
adjacent
show yeah i'm saying before i'm like ben
affleck's my last card
i'm turning to chris wood to make that
victor connection
what um hey guys hey man how are you sir
what so wait what you were a musical
theater guy
correct my thing man all through college
and
high school and growing up that was like
aside from making movies on my super
eight that was my
that was my other hobby um what is uh
and look uh for those that don't follow
very closely
chris has acted for a long time i met
him
um playing man l when i was directing
supergirl episodes of course as i
said he's playing our he-man uh what was
the vampire show that muse loves that
you were on
uh the vampire diaries yeah yeah vampire
diaries as well and stuff
um and and uh he's a wonderful actor and
he's
a gorgeous human being but you're always
you have the kindest intros in the world
kevin you're
uh i come on just blushing every time i
talk
to you it's it's he's he's wonderful
this is what i want to lay out there
he is a [ __ ] hell of a writer
outstanding oh wow it's still going
and you know that like and i'm not just
saying it's a butter mop because we
could totally just talk about he-man and
that's it but like
uh i've read a script that he wrote that
was in that took me back to 1994 where i
was like
this is what i felt like when i saw
indie film like it reignited
a love for indie film because the the
film was
impressionistic and wonderful and
original and singular
and vision and stuff and nobody will
ever make it
[Music]
all of the qualities of a terrific
independent thing you got
he got some pushback on the movie some
people like this
what but but he wrote didn't you write a
script that went someplace
legit and whatnot are you allowed to
talk yeah
it's not it's not public yet but we're
uh that's not public
that wasn't in the trades or anything
like that not yet man it's still like
under the table wheeling and dealing all
right well we can't say what it is but i
can tell you right now
it's like it's it's something that you
and i would work
our whole lives to achieve and we've
been doing and all we have is
all we have is writing and this
[ __ ] has
everything in life and he's about to
have that as well worth it
well worth it because he's wonderful at
the written word what do you attribute
that to
uh the written word yeah where'd you
come where'd you how come
how come you're such a good writer oh
well that's for
thank you first of all um writing i i i
always kind of did it i think i was like
you kev where i when i was a kid i just
no one was giving me pages to shoot or
to have my friends put on plays in the
garage so i had to write my own words so
i've just kind of always done it
i remember writing plays and i was i'd
write up 30 pages of a script when i was
13 years old and hand it out to my
cousins and we perform it
for all of our aunts and uncles and
grandparents
kind of i've always done it just never
been paid for it
yeah that that's the dream is to get
paid for it at the same time
i saw when uh my man got married he
whipped out beautiful words as well like
you know where you get to like
say you're about to there you go there's
that word vowel so
it's like just helping it what do we
call those uh those promises
we make i smoked those away
his even his vows were like in
beautiful like incredibly well [ __ ]
written
beautiful choice of words look my missus
oh i mean
yes and then who went first was it you
or her who went first
first and that's why i couldn't i
couldn't speak through mine
yeah both of them got real beautiful and
the thing is i knew
i knew woody was a writer because i read
his script and whatnot
um didn't the homegirl open with like
i'm not a writer and then dropped like
one of the most beautiful [ __ ]
speeches that you've ever heard in your
life it was really great really special
to be there for man
point is this kid right here as well the
point is
one day he's gonna take my advice and
write himself his own [ __ ] lead in
the movie that he should make
particularly that one that i love
and make a movie because he's got all
the ingredients like you know
so like me i was like i want to make a
movie but like i had to
hire actors and [ __ ] like that we're not
higher but beg them to be in it
thank god they were but like he could
write himself apart and be that
[ __ ] part and direct himself in the
park because he's been on enough sets
and knows how the process works so what
you're saying is he's unfair
[Music]
i don't want to say it in front of him
i'm so sorry um take us into for those
watching uh at home uh
talk a little bit about vampire diaries
when did that was that the first thing
you did
that was that was one of my early
kind of like public roles um i had done
some stuff
um before that nothing really that
caught on with a fan base that was sort
of the first thing i did where
people got excited about a character i
was doing um and wanted more of them so
they
they wrote me more stuff um yeah that
was that was
i guess i started on that seven years
ago
eight years ago and what was the did you
leave
like did they kill you off did you leave
gracefully did you leave because you
were like i don't want to do this yeah
yeah i was i was a bad guy so with like
all good villains
and uh in our favorite shows they
they have to meet some sort of demise or
just
you know go into a spin-off it's kind of
either or
uh or they're skeletor and then
they just exist forever as an equal
force
the um how do you so wait what so
aft how long were you done with that
show
before you went and did supergirl so i
did a couple things after that um i did
a
mini series and i was on a limited
series uh called containment
about a pandemic much like what we're
living in now
a little too timely i kind of don't
recommend it at the moment
but uh um but yeah i did that and then
right
after that ended um that's when i went
up to vancouver
so wait and if i remember craig did
containment did julie pleck do that
didn't she also
yeah yeah that was julie pleck who did
vampire diaries she kind of
pulled me across um from that experience
when you're making when you're making
when you're making it are you like silly
fictional world
this will never happen i'll never need
to remember any of this
you know what i i feel like in a way the
show kind of prepared me
for the quarantine because i read so
much about the spanish flu
and about outbreaks and what actually
happened so when this all started
happening i was like guys no no this is
this is real
like when people who play lawyers think
they're lawyers
it was kind of one of those things
suddenly i thought i knew
i was like send me in i'm ready guys
was there any containment swag that you
got to keep like oh
they sent me all these masks i got all
of these masks
i wish i wish i think i have some uh
dog tags and uh
that's about it um all right so wait so
when who did they come after you to be
come audition for supergirl or how does
that happen
that was the first time in in my career
where um i got offered something without
reading for it um which was kind of
amazing
um and i played hard to get for a second
because i wasn't sure if it was
the right colored spandex um
i was always more of a batman guy than a
superman
and uh and then eventually it clicked
and
apparently there was some part of me
that knew i was gonna
meet my future wife in the mother of my
children so
i guess it all worked out um i mean
yeah and aside from just getting to play
like a hero and stuff it
it gave you the rest yeah the rest of
your life
very the rest of my life which is a
pretty lucky thing to get from a job
usually the job doesn't serve you that
um
so that was pretty fantastic and there
are very few people
like that could walk away from the cw
like gone and that built the rest of my
life
you know what i'm saying like that's
that's well it does match the network
that matches my initials
should be something like that
i think it's somewhere in the rulebook i
don't know where
i just put that together uh when wendy's
girl walks into wendy's and is like
i will take all of your hamburgers i'm
wendy
[Laughter]
when you uh when you when they gave you
the suit finally
which is something like you know for for
the run of the show
was something you would look forward to
and then finally they do give you the
suit
looked tight how was it uncomfortable as
it looked
oh yeah they're terrible it's uh it's
the worst thing you'll ever wear in your
life
it's uh you know it's like a giant
which a onesie is known for comfort and
relaxation
and too many zippers uh this is
as few of zippers as you can have
including no accessibility to use the
restroom
uh and you really can't move in them it
kind of squeezes
your everything if there's a thing that
can be squeezed that is squeezed by the
spandex
so things are going like your elbows
going up to your shoulder and you're not
really sure why
you know that you're not controlling it
uh it's it's an odd experience
but um but yeah i'll tell you what those
lunch breaks were always very
it was like a great release to unzip the
spandex
just like lay on the couch tell them
what it's like to be
up on the you know the harness thing man
when you have to do flying [ __ ] when you
have to green's fun it's uh that that's
one of the really
um that that's when you feel like you're
on the trampoline in your backyard as a
kid
to fight in the invisible villains it's
literally the same thing except someone
is
doing the jumping for you with a rope
you know um
but that's when you really you get to
play and you feel like a kid and
that those are my favorite those the the
big action sequences
they're a bear to shoot because they
take you know days to shoot
two minutes as you know um but uh
when you're in when you're actually
doing the thing that it's a
it's a great time um how long
before you think like because i know it
ain't happening now
um how many years from now do you think
it'll be
before you and melissa are like
let's watch the episodes and
and see and see if we can like spot the
chemistry
like see if like i can see myself
falling in love and blah blah blah do
you think you'll ever get there
you know i think it's probably all over
every second of every frame
so it's you could probably just uh start
at the beginning and then
the first second on screen probably in
some way shape or form go oh yeah there
it is there's the
there's the first i believe um i believe
that mr broadway
i absolutely missed away i can i tell
him a quick broadway story i
i actually went to a broadway show where
i got to sit next to
mr chris wood did you now oh man
it's beautiful um so we go see
beautiful is the show ah the carole king
musical it was all so beautiful
it was beautiful and it was beautiful
branded and
in my heart um the lead
of the show that night uh is of
particular interest to both me and mr
wood
him a lot more uh melissa
benoist rhymes with moist uh i learned
that from chris wood
um it sounds awfully romantic
one evening i used to say benoist all
the time
i don't know why i was like benoit and
then i and then i
and then i shot you with sex i was like
you know it's like
the noise like moist like a chocolate
decadent chocolate cake
that was the most christopher walken
thing i've ever heard
it's like moist
and delicious like a chocolate cake like
a chocolate cake
[Laughter]
we're watching beautiful and we're
watching uh melissa
open this is the debut the first opening
night
of uh the show and
chris is there um a bunch of people that
love melissa there
[ __ ] linda carter was there wonder
woman what yes wonder woman was there to
watch supergirl how awesome is that
um curtain opens and it opens with
melissa she's up top like bang singing
right at the top of the show
and i'm sitting right next to chris wood
who is
crying crying those joyful tears
of seeing his lady love dream come true
she always wanted is that her first
broadway performance
it was his face first
and last first and last she's not gonna
do it again no
no no no no i'm just kidding she i know
that was your first
lifelong dream she was like that that's
what she you know she's like
chris she's a theater kid a couple
musical kids and stuff
drama kids so the idea of broadway
say nerds it's okay drama nerds the idea
of broadway like
you know that that was the goal it
wasn't like one day i'm gonna be super
girl that was the surprise
and the delight where she met the love
of her life and stuff
but the dream was broadway and her dream
came true
and as you know if she if the curtains
open and melissa was crying
like of course like you know people
forgive it because they're like oh look
at her dreams coming true
the fact that he was ballin i was like
oh my god she's got the right guy
like all of the joy he felt for her
joy as she was concentrating on doing
the very thing that she
dreamed about doing performing so she
can't just stop the
show and be like can you [ __ ] believe
this which is how she feels inside
he's expressing for her just by
emotional he was he was crying it was
one of the most beautiful things man
in the world i'm not ashamed of it no
sure should you be
you shouldn't be it was so [ __ ]
wonderful so supportive but he is a
point of the story such a broadway kid
[Laughter]
uh i too was saying that you could say
i'm a jelly
i'm a jellicle somebody could explain
that i too was sitting next to chris
wood when he was crying
but it was in new orleans in a in a
in the waiting room to shoot a scene
for reboot and he's like listen i uh i
gotta fly back to vancouver and my
flight is like
20 minutes from now and we haven't shot
yet
and it's 4am and i'm a little bit daffy
in the brain
yeah we were we were drinking we were on
like coffee number four
yeah like obviously like um and i looked
at my watch and i went
oh my flight's at 6 30.
[Laughter]
anytime you're ready kim we got it done
the boys were so sweet they came out
um uh chris and jesse wrath came out
and they're in jay and samba reboot
during chronicon
um if you haven't seen it on amazon
prime
with the most most extensive and
detailed backstory
screen time has ever had in the history
of home
there's a story in those eyes if you
look closely oh my god he's working
uh but he's sitting next to mr mark
bernard yes
throughout the night and it was we ran
up against it what time do we finally
shoot you guys
you must have been i don't even remember
5 15 or something like that and then
rush
them to the airport so they could get on
plane go back to vancouver correct
that's right i had to get back to work
such as
it's such a blast though and thank you
again for letting us come out and play
that was
such a trip um it just means that uh
one day your kids are gonna watch that
movie
and be like they're both in this
terrible movie who are jay and silent
pop
was this before you guys met on
supergirl why would you be in a movie
like this
uh let's talk he-man what have you
had you done voice work prior to he-man
so when i was broke living in new york
um in between
babysitting for three boys on the upper
west side
to make cash so i could support my
acting aspirations
i bought a little usb
microphone and i joined this i can't
even remember the name of the site it
was some
like freelance voiceover
site where you join and you can record
audio samples and submit auditions and i
would
that was the only voice work i had done
i would i was making like 100 bucks here
and there
doing a voiceover for a animated
hey kids don't run in the cafeteria like
a school psa
or i did some military psa
teaching soldiers etiquette and the
barracks and
so strange uh but that was all i had
done
tell them about how how uh
what acting in front of a microphone is
like because it is acting and in some
ways
oh yeah it's way more acting than one
can do
on a camera on a camera one could be
subtle you can't be so
behind a microphone you got to
communicate emotion just with the voice
tell them about it
you know it's so funny i i actually i
would describe
voice acting as incredibly physical
work whereas camera acting it's all you
know it's what you're feeling it's
it's they say it's through your eyes
which actually means
they're seeing through your eyes to your
soul right if you're feeling something
we'll see it
but for voice acting we don't see
anything it's all
voice so you really have to
take the feeling and elevate it and
sometimes it helps to physically express
it and so
people sweat in the booth and they get
you know they grit their teeth and they
stomp into the ground and really you
have to really dig
in to grab the emotion and kind of
amplify it otherwise
you're just kind of talking like you do
on film and nothing's really happening
and no one cares
uh which is sort of what american acting
is a lot of time we kind of just try not
to
seem like we're interesting and i care
about anything
is that the secret to acting did you
just let it
is that all acting or just cw acting
what kind of acting are you talking
about
i'm actually doing a master class series
[Laughter]
early um acting and basically the first
lesson is to speak his monotone
and enunciate as little as possible
[ __ ] work
[ __ ] worked out you married supergirl
for heaven's sakes
mumble away kids that's that's what your
future looks like if you can mumble your
way through a performance
so what you're saying is voice acting
then is very much like theater acting
where like you've got to play to the
back row right like
you can't see that person's eye from
thank you [ __ ] excellent job now
there's a writer
mark bernard is a writer and the kitties
are asleep
yes your theater training really comes
in handy in that [ __ ] i never [ __ ]
put that together
yeah because you you learn how to take a
truthful feeling and amplify it that's
what
that's what the best stage acting is
right um
an emotion that an actor is feeling that
can reach the back of the house and
with voice acting it's that same sort of
thing but your relationship is with the
microphone
um and it needs to go through the
microphone and then into the character
and then the audience gets it so it is
it's a whole
there is a learning curve i feel like it
takes a second
hopefully we got it right now you're
what's so fun you are way younger than
us
so i don't know if like was he-man in
your wheelhouse growing up or that was
before you
he-man yeah he-man was on uh
we didn't have cable when i was a kid
because
we didn't have the money for it uh so i
was
watching they were rerunning it on i
think
i'm trying to think what network it
would have been i can't even think of
the names of what they were
back then but they were running it was
the rerun after the original series had
aired
because i would watch that and i would
watch x-men those are my cartoons
where'd you grow up in new york in ohio
ohio i don't know dublin ohio home of
wendy's
yeah that's right that's true that's
where wendy's begins is in ohio yeah
and there's a callback to wendy
so this guy there's a
there's a writer there's a writer
there's a writer
high five um what uh
uh you know i we got to be very careful
of course in what we talk about
in masters universe all of us are nd8 up
the
a h um what uh
you got to play two different characters
uh what was that like
that was one of the fun aspects of
prince adam slash
e-man it's finding these very different
placements for the same person right so
it has to
it has to feel like the same character
but that
their emotional states are right prince
adam is sort of in a different place
um he's covering he's deflecting uh
he's more fun and goofy and then he-man
we have to drop to the truth of his core
mission you know to to save the world so
uh
i mean it starts with registers right
that was the
that was the easy part prince adam is
supposed to be full of youth so he's a
little higher
and a little more excited and then
he-man
go down and be more heroic down in the
basement and use his
his big fighty fight voice
it's uh it's pretty awesome like you
join a tradition
of storytelling in which performers get
to be
two people like you know whoever plays
batman gets to do bruce wayne
and then they get to do the dark knight
whoever plays superman gets to do clark
kent
and then they get to do the man of steel
so you get to do prince adam
and then you also get to be his heroic
alter ego man it's a
that's right wonderful fraternity that
you join
what although i hear i'm in i'm in deep
trouble
uh because the internet has found out
that i am not bulking up
you're not doing the work for my
performance
somebody on twitter was just like chris
wood he's not
big enough to play he man and they meant
in size
have you seen his thighs his thighs are
not nearly yeah he skips leg day all the
time
but you're right
he can't possibly play the character
yeah i had to point out i was like you
know i better get in touch with
netflix and see if they'll send chris
some steroids in a
[ __ ] peloton so he could do the voice
in an
animated series also chris is not from
another planet
that's also an issue could you not have
cast an indigenous actor
to play somebody from eternia i forget
who was it tweeted somebody tweeted
something about griffin
newman they were like oh i tell griffin
we got to cut his [ __ ] legs off
maybe it was there texted that tweeted
that
um what uh the uh now that you voice
acted
uh and led uh you know an animated
series
is it something you see yourself doing
again i mean of course
hopefully we all get to do this one
again but other stuff you got like one
of them disney voices and you could sing
like a [ __ ] man
oh man i would love to do disney too
let's uh
put that in the bucket list i honestly i
i get a real kick out of it it's um
like you said you can really go to a
larger-than-life place
and it all it always has to come from
you know something sincere that sense of
play has to be grounded in something
um you just kind of yell and scream i
think people can hear that
so there is a challenge to it but it's
also super
rewarding because you get to you know
play characters that fly on
cats that are oversized and wear armor
and jellicle cats
none of that jellicle [ __ ] in our show
mark
battle cats what kind of jetical are you
i'm a cringer cat
somebody point a sword at me quick um
yeah man it's uh it's pretty long life
with p-man too because this
i mean the character is so fun and uh
obviously
i i had the action figures when i was a
kid and those toys
i hope to introduce my my son to
masters of the universe via the action
figures because they're i mean they're
they're so weird they really
went out there have you seen that
special that they do on the toys on that
uh the netflix show
oh yeah the toy the wonderful uh toys
the main toys that made us die
yeah the toys that made us their he-man
episode is unbelievably wonderful
and it and it just shows you you know
they were thinking what
weird crap would a little boy like put
together on a toy
and then they end up with these wild
names and these characters would do
insane things and it's it's part of why
it's so fun
um and the fact that they found out
found a way to build build a story
around those
bizarre toys that was also compelling
thank god they
thank god they did 30 years later it's
amazing we thank god they did we all
have [ __ ] jobs
all three of us you're right
um wait so uh before we let you go
um it occurs to me that uh melissa just
had
her episode heir of supergirl that she
directed
directorial debut that's right did you
did the the the the wood the noise or
benoist woods did you guys
like kick back and watch it together you
know we didn't because we don't
have cable
don't know don't don't let cw hear that
or
perhaps do and they'll pay for cable why
don't you have cable where are you
quarantining
we're in we're we're in california so
we're home but we're usually not home
right oh my gosh that's right fortunate
actor
you you moved to california to never be
there
that's i was i was shooting in new york
and she was shooting in vancouver
when this all started and we were lucky
to get home quickly but uh
but yeah i mean you we don't spend that
much time
in our house so we don't have cable
tell them why you were in new york was
it the that's been announced right uh
yeah yeah for 30 something uh 30
something else which is an abc show that
hopefully knock on knock on me hopefully
ends up going when we when we get out of
this situation
uh with kovid yeah it's a reboot of 30
another
another 80s classic oh my god
you'll have two yeah you'll have [ __ ]
uh masters of the universe and 30
something
i watched 30 something in real time i
was a kid i loved that show my mom
watched it so i watched it with her and
stuff
so i know all about hope and michael and
i saw that they were redoing the show
and then i saw that [ __ ] chris was
involved i was like what and i texted
him are you
[ __ ] for real and [ __ ] and you're
playing
hope and michael's did they announce
that i don't know yeah i'm their young
under
their son so he's tied in
he's legacy character legacy characters
legacy
oh that's all about [ __ ] dope man so
i mean i
look i can't wait to watch that but i
have seen and heard
four animatics so far on masters of the
universe and
oh man your performance i cannot wait
it's wonderful
you did a great great job and made me
proud as the guy who was like
you know who'd be good this guy put you
forward this guy and they're like
who's that and you're like hang on yes
let me tell you
here let me pull up imdb they knew who
he was they know you man if you did it
like the music man it wouldn't have been
an issue
you know would be good would would be
good if he could do that i bet you would
could
[Laughter]
that was a deep cut hell yes look at you
look at how you came to life
with a little theater riff man
jazz hands all around oh yeah you can
feel the jazz hands from there
in the cantina touching us all over uh
go back
and enjoy uh the rest of your thursday
night thanks for hanging out with us say
hello to you gentlemen
to the good lady benoist and whatnot it
was wonderful seeing you both
good to see you sir excellent soon be
well all right guys give it up for
he-man himself chris wood everybody
marnell flies away
he's so good such a good guy i forgot he
was such a [ __ ] theater kid
that's right and we were like talking
theater and [ __ ] and i forgot his
connection to garber
one more we wrote in we have another
point of entry that's true
that's good um i'm telling you i'm
[ __ ] around his script was one of the
most impressive things i've ever yeah
that's awesome and it did make me feel
jealous when i'm like he's that pretty
and he can write like this
like all i had was writing this is a
problem
god what a good guy all right you know
what
we gather together to
find out the news here and mark went
and found it and he'll read it now
wow thank you that's my thanksgiving
song that was amazing mark used to be in
the news
he knows how to find news you may not
know he [ __ ] knows and he found some
news he's
gonna give it to us give it up for mark
he's got some news ladies and gentlemen
news news news from new york no good
news is good
good news from gary ganu nice
it's the great space coaster wow it's
good cuts
very deep cuts deep cuts um all right
kids
mark's got news what do you got that's
why i come it's wonderful to talk to
chris wood but i can do that at home i
can text him and [ __ ] like that
here i come because mark's got the news
i care how else am i gonna get the news
what go on the internet [ __ ] that it's
too scary don't do that
all bad news out there i want good news
news i come here man
john krasinski show and mark bernard
those are the only two sources of good
news these days
and how i haven't seen that john
krazinski show have you watched it
uh i i only saw the one episode i saw
the hamilton episode sounds incredibly
sweet
it you know it seems like such a nice
guy it seems adorable
i can't actually handle that much sweet
like it actually just hurts my teeth
is that right a little too sacred for
mark bernard like
like i hate that [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
good for him but [ __ ] that
yeah too much you gotta leave this news
a little bit
um that's uh you look at the camera like
he did in the
office when that show begins yes
oh my god that was good it's pretty damn
good
uh hey so you hey hey
how you doing hey yo mookie i don't know
oh my god is that your rosie perez it's
not quite i didn't go high enough for
rosie perez not bad though i knew what
you were talking about what's your
problem
uh quince
that is my uh that's my white man can't
jump rosie perez
i will take food that begin with cue
alex look
camera's on so i'm not gonna even
attempt my
rosie perez i'll let you keep going
like go ahead take yourself a hole let's
see if your brown card gets you out of
this one champ
uh so you you are a fan of two things
that this is about and i've only seen
one of them
okay clone wars and the mandalorian
well what look how interested i got
jc suddenly [ __ ] woke up in the booth
where he's like somebody's talking star
wars
um battle star galactica star and star
wars veteran
katie sackoff joining the mandalorian
season two
i held once too fast so i didn't have
enough breath to inhale the second time
let me let me exhale what's the third
thing uh no it was just the two things
it was
oh sorry i can go back to normal
breathing you can go back to normal
breathing um
baby sackoff royalty for those of us who
love b-star g man she played [ __ ]
starbuck
for heaven's sakes played the [ __ ] out
of that part man i really did
yeah really did and she was also in the
very short-lived bionic woman show where
she was the bad guy i remember
yeah i i barely remember that show but
she was in it she was fine in it
i met her at a con in l.a man she's good
people i like her
she's real you've had her on your
[ __ ] show listen to me i'm like i ran
across her once in a parking lot mark's
like
she's been in this bar talking to me bro
give me the mic
twice yeah go ahead sorry never mind
where i've
encountered katie's i saw her in the
world once personal friend
so this is big news for you this is
welcome she didn't say anything about
this
um she's lying in your friendship you
can't be that good a friend she uh she
she winked about it once or twice did
she where she's like i couldn't talk
about it
record the mandalorian it's not
like i'm back in the delorean no the
mentality i'm nodding like that's how
she do but
i don't know i don't know no she was
very she she kept to her
mda she kept uh she kept the word she
kept her bond
um word is bond word is bond and so wait
didn't she
play this part back to the day in the
clone wars yes
so she's already voiced this part and
now she's going to play this part in
real life irl
irl i look i just want to take this
opportunity again
go here give me a give me give me a two
shot right give him that give him that
thank you john favreau and dave filoni
probably on this count a little more
dave filoni right
um because this is the same season we're
gonna see some ahsoka
in the show we're gonna see this
character i like that man i like i'm
happy for this dave filoni
for many reasons i'm happy because i'm
[ __ ] some wonderful [ __ ] to watch
but i'm happy because like all his
characters that he put in the cartoons
and [ __ ]
are now coming over into the live action
style the real world and stuff like that
so yeah i mean and i think people at
least deep cut
fans uh hardcore fans of the clone wars
thought that she
might be coming for season two once you
end the
the season one finale with um gideon
moff gideon holding the saber which
apparently was
bokeh tan's thing to control or hold or
lose
during the show i'm still not up to that
point so she's gonna that's what she's
coming to hunt
it could very well be but yes she is
another mandalorian she's coming for
season two i'm coming for season two
we're all coming for season two
can't wait i hear it's not delayed it's
coming on october
yeah they finished production in uh in
apparently like
good we'll all be locked down until then
still then but they finished production
they wrapped in like
late february early march before
everything shut down
and so they've been doing post remotely
and so yeah they're sticking to their
schedule
of october day can't wait can't wait
that [ __ ] show is magic
magic charles it seems like when carl
weather shouts
mando there's gonna be like more than
one person who turns around because like
we're all mandalorians dude
um man oh man that's gonna be cool is
there more there is more mando news
isn't there um i don't know do you have
more mando news i do
boba fett's going to be in this season
all right they hired the guy who played
boba fett
and go to jc he must know the name jc
cam star wars news who they hire to play
jeremy bullock no jim he was the one who
played it in the prequels
django yeah and so dave filoni god bless
his heart
he he loves george lucas and he loves
them prequels man
believes in those prequels and likes
bringing [ __ ] over into real world
didn't abandon them prequels wasn't like
everybody else and like you know the
prequels
one day i said that to him i was
interviewing lucasfilm for geeking out
the show that i did
with greg grumberg and uh you know i was
like hey man but you know come on
bugging the prequels right and he was
like no no no
and he did a [ __ ] quick deep dive on
why the prequels are important and
[ __ ] amazing
and he converted me right there in the
room really oh he was good could he come
to my house and do that too
maybe he jedi mind tricked me baby he's
like you love those prequels
no dude love those requests i do love
those i don't know why my voice went up
like that
said the cameras are on um
all right yes that's well so boba fett
then
let's stop and talk about that
well how mark is boba fett going to be
in mandalorian season two
when boba fett in this timeline would be
dead in the sarlacc pit correct
perhaps he clawed out of the sarlacc pit
seems like a dumb way for an actual
mandalorian to die doesn't it
it sure [ __ ] does you mean they're
gonna go back and rectify one of the
only bad things
other than ewoks about return of the
jedi
that boba fett goes out the way he goes
there is a comic book story marvel did
years ago in the comics after return of
the jedi was done
that was a story of boba fett that very
thing getting out of the sarlacc pit he
was like burped up and [ __ ] and he was
unconscious and
he comes out crawls out of the sarlacc
pit and doesn't know who he is
and then winds up working with if i
remember correctly han solo and stuff
and then only at the end of the
adventure is he like
wait a second i'm boba fett and then he
gets knocked back into the sarlacc pit
so they didn't affect continuity at all
but
if they're bringing this guy out the
sarlacc if they do that issue of the
comic book
i mean [ __ ] dude like i already love
those two dudes and [ __ ] baby yoda
and all that [ __ ] but if they did that
story
if they redeem boba fett all of this
will have been worth it
[ __ ] that well that's true but for me
personally
if they were to do that comic book story
my entire childhood would be validated
there i said it there you go um that is
cool that's true they could save boba
fett
some people bitching online about
knowing that and we're part of the
problem because we just shared that
information
sorry but they're like i didn't know
about baby yoda and i liked it a lot
more now we know boba fett's here we
know ahsoka's in it we know too much and
i don't know keep feeding me those
details i'll forget i'm a stoner so by
the time the show starts i'll be like
holy [ __ ] ahsoka's on it
like did you know we had chris wood as a
guest today yeah
we did i've already forgotten um cut to
the jc cam would you
you got any thoughts on this uh star
wars nonsense
i'm sorry is this not your bar what do
you mean boba fett's not cool boba fett
was the ultimate cool
boba fett why am i looking at the camera
boba fett um
like he was a man of mystery that
[ __ ] outfit was so badass
it works as the mandalorian what do you
i mean i do think it's awesome that
tamara morrison's coming back to play
the grown-up version of the kid that
daniel logan played before
that is
yeah because he wanted his own clone
that's who boba fett was
um but wait [ __ ] that ain't the issue
what do you mean bubba
wasn't that cool that didn't do it for
you who was your favorite star wars
character as a kid
cut back to this camera holy [ __ ]
this [ __ ] mary sue over here
worshiping the hero with no
powers and suddenly him fighting
fighting the empire and [ __ ] like
really you went for luke in a big bad
way
when i was like two or three years old
and i'm
i don't have an older brother han solo
is the older brother you look up to
i was always the older brother i was
so young that i wanted to be like i'm
the guy who likes superman instead of
batman and i've been that my whole life
because
i was always the oldest sibling
and i was always looking to be the like
you know
hero buy that i buy that and that's also
like uh
that's i guess yeah if you were hey man
i like luke skywalker chances are you
were like hey man i like superman as
well if you were inclined to like
comic book characters at all like what
are the chances you're like i love luke
skywalker and i [ __ ] love
batman i mean you know you can like
batman a lot but like
one you know luke skywalker is just like
it's light versus dark right like luke
skywalker is [ __ ] just
tidy white super bright blonde you know
just the
force of light in the universe and
superman is the same thing batman
is none more dark and han solo is a
little bit that
kind of vader's definitely that batman's
kind of like a combination of han solo
and darth vader
yes he's a good guy but ain't too good
you know don't [ __ ] do what needs to
be done and [ __ ] justice
he'll shoot a dude in a [ __ ]
banquette
at a cantina i like that and then throw
a [ __ ] quarter on the bar and be like
for the mess
that's zack snyder's [ __ ] batman
right there man [ __ ] brandon
do you think you can clean up a mess for
a quarter burning flesh
do you know how expensive it is to get
blood out of this naugahyde
jc you ever had anybody killed in the
bar and then somebody could
somebody pitch you a quarter
jc be there with insurance forms going
i'm sorry you're gonna have to stay
until the police get here but that
quarter is not going to cover this at
all
i'm sorry this is like a ten thousand
dollar bill dude i gotta go hey man but
it's a
canteen a bar hey that story
happened a long time ago in a galaxy
far far away here we got lawyers and
also to avoid any copyright infringement
this is not the thing that happens in
this bar yeah and by the way
cantina existed long before those movies
so that's why it's cool to use and so
did the word scum
and villainy so
so we'll just cut that out later
so yes kitty sackoff is replying live
oh katie zackoff back to her yeah as
bokutan and the mandalorian
um i support this 1000 look more work
for katie sackoff i think she's [ __ ]
amazing come on
starbuck what a [ __ ] character and
she played the [ __ ] out of it man she's
good
like crazy funny a little dirty she yeah
i mean i talked to her only for a little
bit and she's very
like now she's sharp as attack yeah a
lot of fun
once again i'm like hey i can vouch for
you like bro i know
we do shows together all right so that's
good news and we got more star wars news
out of it too
with boba fett i don't know how you
didn't have that maybe i should handle
the [ __ ] news from now on right but
next story
no no no
no this is fine i'm much i'm happy with
the setup
uh what do we got next mark um did you
ever read a comic called sweet tooth
that's jeff lemire yeah he did for dc it
is uh
it is now getting the netflix treatment
straight to series order
from producer robert downey jr what what
the king of marvel is making a dc
something
he is indeed uh good work is good work
man
jeff lemire's canadian kid is he i
believe so he seems very sweet
um wow that's [ __ ] dope man good for
him
right to series that's good that means
none of this [ __ ] like well we'll
develop it and if we like it then maybe
we'll like they're like straight to
series go bro it's that good
yeah you know and it's if you're not
familiar with the book it's uh sort of
the storybook adventures of gus who's
part deer part boy
who leaves his home in the forest to
find the outside world ravaged by a
cataclysmic event
he joins a ragtag family of humans and
animal children hybrids like himself
in search of answers about this new
world and the mystery behind his hybrid
origins
so you know that old story that old
story
um yeah so robert downey jr and his wife
susan are
sort of executive producing jim mikel
who did a show called happen leonard i
want to say that was for ifc
and beth schwartz from arrow
um yeah an assistant who eventually rose
to become show runner yeah yeah she was
the last showrunner on the last season
of arrow
um they're running this show and they're
petting the script um
the cast blah blah blah blah
don't know who most of these people are
except for will forte
oh i love him i [ __ ] love him oh my
god he's so funny
and thanos's dad is going to provide the
narrator he's going to be the voice of
the show
thanos's dad james brolin oh
the elder brother the elder brother [ __ ]
man mr barbara streisand
indeed mr streisand wow all right well
good for them everyone got work except
us
uh that's good man more quality
programming i love netflix everything
they do is a-okay with me
masters of the universe coming in 20-21
hold that smile
and release um and also like robert
downey jr i'm all for him man i [ __ ]
i like that guy i like his work yeah
he's got taste
i haven't seen do little but i support
it hey he's got taste most of the time
all right what else you got um do you
remember when we talked lottie's many
years ago
yeah about swamp thing yeah it's done it
was finished it was done it was finished
get out of the swamp you know it's done
we like the show it premiered on the dc
universe
um very shortly after its premiere it
was cancelled
um they only made nine or something they
made 10. they cut the order from 13 down
to 10.
okay um there was all kinds of talk
about the reasons for its cancellation
was it storage for the very expensive
sets because they built the whole
[ __ ] swamp indoors like
dagobah it was gonna cost some millions
to store the set
right you know and then there's it was
maybe the most expensive show that they
were producing at the time for the dc
universe app
and so maybe the cost was prohibited
like just any number of
factors could have come into the reason
why it's canceled but it was
the cw however in trying to um
corona proof their fall schedule was
like hey
you mean to tell me that there's like 10
episodes of superhero content that's
just laying there that most people
haven't seen who didn't have the dc
universe app
welcome to the network my friends like
let's and they're they're turning it
into a show
they're they're just re-airing the
episodes that have already been aired so
will they keep going or no
um based on the reaction if the reaction
is through the roof then perhaps
nice that'll be the widest audience
they've probably had they might gin it
up but it's it's part of the
you know cw announced their fall [ __ ]
their fall season they're saving all
their superhero stuff
to january 2021. so they're not
launching until
so we won't see the beginning of the
seasons where we normally do in
september right they're pushing their
season back
basically six months right four or five
months um because production is supposed
to begin for fall seasons
in like june or july like cameras have
to start rolling in order to make
september premieres and they've just
recently told us we're gonna be until
how long
um they've said end of july we're sort
of still sheltering at home
but they haven't even begun to really
like wrap their minds around what it's
going to take for production to start
again
location shooting sound stage shooting
you've got crews of a couple hundred
people
sometimes out in the world you got
extras you got like there's
there's so many moving pieces that all
need to be sort of found
you know ways to lock them down and make
it safe for your actors to come out and
do actor stuff
and make it safe for your crews to come
out and do crew stuff or
you know a vaccine would be awesome
hurry up science we're waiting on you
science mm-hmm
um so so the cw's doing what i imagine a
lot of networks will do is they will
acquire
already produced television shows to put
on the air
as part of their fall season or like
stuff that had been mid-season
previously and never made it on like oh
hey we shot 10 episodes of this thing
put it on the air you know what they
need mark is a
show that deep dives on pop culture
can be shot out of a vacant cantina no
doubt
[Laughter]
where we talk about all things cw and
the whatnot
so i don't know it's putting it out
there you know we can fill
three hours of a night easy easy
easy i be people would tune in too even
if we just talked
like arrowverse shows um they'd be like
oh my god i love those shows
we're like roll a clip they're like and
the clip is just an episode
roll a clip this clip is 48 minutes long
one of my favorite moments in the
arrowverse was the entire season finale
of flash
uh let's watch it yeah let's roll it out
thanks
uh what else we got um speaking of the
cw they're
they're already planning their crossover
event for next season
boy they're optimistic they're very
active what do they know
um oh my god i'm so i'm sorry i'm so
baked so i'm so tired it's not the
company
i'm just in the also in the middle of a
48-hour fast
so i'm not you know i'm not saying i'm
low energy i'm a little bit
sleepy and more than that i'm baked
you're running on the vapors
a little bit a little but not in a bad
way where i'm like [ __ ] this
show i'm glad i'm here because it means
that i'm not going to
succumb to eating tonight and i will
make it to 48 hours and stuff
anyway we are here for you kevin thank
you thank you
[ __ ] me back to the news um so yeah
they're already planning their next
crossover event it will be somewhat less
ambitious
than the crisis on infinite earths oh
well that's [ __ ] because now i'm
accustomed to something [ __ ] huge
no whatever whatever they want to give
us is fine what is it a zoom call
thank you thank you very very nice
current joke thank you
uh topical humor i appreciate that well
you know playing playing to the world
that's where we are now
um they're they're going to constrict it
to superman and lois
and batwoman are going to be their sort
of two
two shows they're going to cross over is
if this is a quarter quad event
the rest are not crossing over or no the
rest so far i mean there's no arrow
anymore um oh good point um i mean they
still have the arrow spin-off
um green arrow and the whatever that was
i forgot the
black canary and the arrows or whatever
or the arrow and black canaries
right um then there's also supergirl
supergirl slash legends of tomorrow
and um
what's the other show that they finally
brought into the universe
black lightning so that yeah so
and and why then would just you would
you just do soup
i think that perhaps they're feeling a
little bit of like we can't
quite go bigger than we went with crisis
center finance anything it's it's the
end game effect right like right
how are we ever going to top this now
they gotta start small you gotta
ratchet back down and maybe tell some
you know we'll take these two new kids
on the block
that women going into its second season
superman and lois just starting
and then just giving some shine to some
characters that don't often
i'm in anything they want to do is they
okay with me
i love the berlanti verse there i said
it
um what else you got uh hey so far good
news i like all these news do you
remember
the uh the ongoing persistent consistent
threat that we will eventually see a new
mutants movie
my god they've been [ __ ] teasing this
[ __ ] for so
long um yeah and then recently i saw
something online where they're like you
could pre-order this on amazon i was
like oh my god they come to their senses
and they're gonna put it online for us
to watch now you're gonna break my heart
aren't you
not at all uh you it is now set for
theatrical release
of august 28th of this year
may i um you my two cents i would uh i
could even give you some changes a guy
that's run a studio
uh look this is just my feeling if
you know we've been in [ __ ] hiding
from this virus for however long we've
been in lockdown
if they let us out into the world
getting people to go into like
hey let's go gather in a cluster is
probably a bad idea and
also it's going to be tough um i say
this as somebody who's a live performer
and that's probably an adjustment i'm
also going to have to make as well
now if you were like [ __ ] hey man you
want to see black widow
the only way you're going to do it is
brave the virus come into the theater
and stuff
i'm i'm i'm i'm there for [ __ ] the
marvel cinematic universe hardcore
so i brave it i'm wearing a mask i'm
wearing gloves i'm [ __ ] bathing
purell but i'm going uh you want to tell
me wonder woman's about to happen
[ __ ] i'll go you know [ __ ] against
all better judgment where i should just
stay in the house
i'm going i got to see this movie i
don't know that i
feel the same way about the new mutants
i want to see it but when i thought i
was going to be able to see it at home i
was like [ __ ] hey man i'll pay you
20 bucks 30 bucks and let me watch it at
home and stuff
but i'll look if it happens i'll go to
the theaters because i'm that [ __ ]
guy i love comic book movies but
most other people are they gonna like
all right i'll brave this [ __ ] because
i want to see the new mutants part of
you know i don't it's
it's i don't know how much of any ties
it has left to the old
x-men universe cinematic universe but
that's closed and gone too
your thoughts and i'm not i'm not
[ __ ] on it i i love josh boone
he directed this um and i want to see
the movie man i [ __ ] bought issue one
in the
new mutants when it hit the stands years
ago and i think the trailer looks
[ __ ] awesome and stuff
but i just i think that's i don't know
if i'd go
theatrical you uh it feels to me
as if they found a solution to the no
win scenario
which was we're probably contractually
obligated to put this out theatrically
but we know that it
i'm not going to say it's not good
because again i haven't seen it i don't
know it but it's been bounced all over
the schedule now for what is almost two
and a half
years but we know that was like some of
that was political and as much as like
the disney
fox sale froze [ __ ] for a while
so right but it's also even before that
yeah it was supposed to be out april
13th 2018
was the very first release so now we
just passed the two-year mark for the
release date they didn't start shooting
then that was when they were going to
release the movie
oh yeah yeah yeah meaning that they shot
it already probably in 2017.
they were they they dropped the first
trailer at cinemacon
2017 which is
april i believe april may is when i feel
so bad for josh boone if
if i like this would you make a movie
and
like nobody gets to see it and [ __ ] like
for years they're like oh we're gonna
move it here it's gonna be here it's
gonna be here
like oh my god man i mean so like when
when a movie like this bounces all over
the schedule
it it it betrays what would seem to be a
lack of faith in the picture
on the part of the studio they they
don't think it's going to be successful
they've recut it
they've done reshoots they've done all
those things you do to a movie to try
and and
push it over the finish line it feels as
if
um releasing it in this incredibly early
kind of
canary in a coal mine fashion is like if
it bombs
we can write it off to audiences we're
not willing to come back to theaters
because of a pandemic not because
they didn't want to see the movie that
makes sense like it allows them to
to both make it like sorry yeah we we
tried
and we weren't ready it's the test case
right it's the the we we put
you know john glenn in a friggin rocket
cycle and we wanted to see how fast we
could go
and if he succeeds great if he doesn't
it was experimental to begin with
put that on a poster man the john glenn
of comic book movies mark bernardin
uh yeah so it's it's if they if they did
have faith that you would pay
20 to do it every like your vod at home
they might stick to it there they might
do it that way if they're contractually
obligated for theatrical release
better to do it now and let it die for
reasons
aren't all contracts off though in a
world of [ __ ]
what's going on but you know what you're
right they're like look we'll put it out
and if it works holds on if not
sorry we tried yeah turns out culture's
not ready for it yet
i want to see it look good to me and it
gives disney
um information it gives them data for
when to start actually releasing the
movies that they have faith in it's when
hey when can we put milan back in the
theaters when can we do black widow when
can we
all these movies that we had pushed if
this works
great we know we can get back up and
running in october november if it
doesn't work
speaking of data yes how is your card
job
the card job is going very very well um
you know we're still working we're still
writing you know there's still no idea
yet when we're gonna get to shoot
um as with most of the the business
everybody's sort of
on the wait and see like who's got the
plan that makes the most sense to be
able to get
everybody back to work but you know
we're in the room
every day we're working every day and
it's fun man it's
it's still a hoot to get to every now
and again right
picard interior spaceship picard and
then write a line of dialogue yeah
[ __ ] it's a ton of fun time of your life
kid all right
next news piece next news speaking of
trying to resume production on [ __ ]
the matrix sequel matrix four is
planning to resume production in july
their shop they weren't done
they were they weren't directing uh lily
i believe wachowski
let me double nope my bad lana which
housekeeper so awashovsky is still
directing
yes but they're not both dylan they're
not doing is in tandem
is the other sibling also
like involved as a writer or anything um
i do not see
lily's name anywhere in the press
release i'm not sure if it was a
schism between them i'm not sure if
there was some shenanigans afoot
but uh but thus far lana's name is the
only wachowski attached to it
uh it's phil it still makes me feel good
that there's obashovsky
directly yes it it definitely is a bit
of like a visionary franchise
yeah standard bearer and just think they
you know
they've had how many years since the
last
matrix well 99 was the first one
so that was 20 years two years ago one
year ago i don't know
so i want to say like 2004 probably and
they did the matrix
revolutions or yes matrix reloaded and
then revolutions was the last one
so 15 plus years 16 years
to hear everybody's bitching complaints
about
hey man the third one and all that [ __ ]
so
you must have a finely tuned [ __ ]
death machine for this matrix you know
what i'm saying like
they didn't have anything to go off of
for matrix reloaded and revolutions
other than matrix
and they did them back to back and then
they were committed to that
now there's been so much time this
thing's going to be sharp
i'm in man i can't wait uh knock on wood
i mean how's he come back he's he died
right
um boilers yeah no he he uh he doesn't
end
well yeah but there's also talk that
there might be a bit of a prequel
vibe to this um even though keanu and
carrie and moss are both coming back
yeah i mean and that's this is years
after the there's 11 years after the
matrix movie well 12
13 years after they've shot it mm-hmm
equal
prequel well they're the one of the some
of this [ __ ] some of this robert downey
jr marvel [ __ ]
i don't know how much of that [ __ ] but
uh yaya abdul mateen ii
yes dr manhattan uh is in the film and
he's rumored to be playing a young
morpheus
really so they're gonna go back in time
they're gonna go back in time
gotta go back in time we're gonna end
game this [ __ ] that good end game this
year
we gotta go back more time travel [ __ ]
with
time it's entertaining every time
i know you can't rhyme time with time
unless one time is with a t-h-y-m-e
like a spice holy [ __ ] man there's a
writer
there's a writer you steal a crown back
chris wood
spice spice baby
that was great but germany like european
and international
uh countries are opening for production
a little bit earlier
because they have had in some cases
better success dealing with the
coronavirus than we have
what no i thought was that possible was
the best at everything and that's
we'll just leave that there and move on
indeed but yeah so germany thinks
they're going to be able to be up and
running by july
yeah new zealand and poland are both
going to be up and running
um and australia and you and germany are
i think coming right behind them yay and
then when are we
unclear meanwhile oh [ __ ] elsewhere
yeah um the sandman
neil gaiman sandman one of the greatest
things ever achieved
by humanity a signal work of comic books
oh it's fantastic
it's being translated to an audible
drama
that's awesome very cool and they just
announced the cast
of said audible drama ooh all right i'm
gonna close my eyes
all right i don't need to do that go
ahead
uh james mcavoy is playing morpheus he's
playing morpheus i [ __ ] co-sign this
he's got a beautiful voice beautiful
voice kat dennings
is gonna be death
from uh from
um she's playing death she's playing
death all right uh
taryn edgerton is john constantine
really yeah get riz ahmed is the
corinthian
oh andy circus is matthew the raven
ah uh michael sheen is lucifer
wait not martin sheen michael machine
is going to play lucifer yes even though
david tennant played the devil in good
omens
yes and even though yeah there's already
and even those are the
lucifer but no relation no um he'll be
good the rendition of lucifer and
you know i mean it's kind of the one
from the tv show but
neil gaiman's straight up first
rendition when when morpheus goes to get
his helm
back from the lord of hell and like
you're expecting there's gonna be this
[ __ ] like
holy [ __ ] man they're gonna [ __ ] get
it on it's gonna be the devil
first dream and [ __ ] and he gets down
there and spoilers he's like i'm done
i'm closing hell guess what you win
here's the key
it's all yours going to earth so [ __ ]
good that's a good choice all right who
else you got
uh see justin vivian bond as desire
miriam margolies is despair ah and then
uh samantha morton bb new worth
arthur darville william hope and josie
lawrence fill out the cast
well do it again slower samantha morton
oh she's good actress bibi new worth oh
my god it's lilith
mm-hmm she's great actors uh not playing
lilith that would be fun
yeah arthur darville who's on doctor who
okay
um william hope and josie lawrence
i don't know who those two are fair
enough yes um i'm in and they're doing
it on audible
audible the first i love audible not
only did they sponsor the jay and zombob
reboot roadshow tour
but they are a huge force in podcasting
number one advertiser in podcast so
people in podcasting that like finally
get an advertiser usually
it's audible so they support the the art
form i totally do uh it debuted the
first part debuts july 15th
what that soon that soon and adapt the
first three volumes of the graphic novel
series
preludes in nocturnes doll's house and
dream country oh my god i
will legit listen to this yeah and
gaiman is narrating it
with his plumbing you buried the [ __ ]
lead on that one why did you say that
first he's the one reading all the
[ __ ]
captions and [ __ ] it's awesome [ __ ]
captions and [ __ ]
um wow that's awesome i never thought
i'd live this long to see something that
beautiful
i wonder if one day they'll do it as a
tv show
um they uh they were doing it as a tv
show but it's still gonna happen right
still gonna happen um you know netflix
netflix with a budget
huge budget i don't know how deep into
pre-production they were
how deep is your prep is your prep how
deep is your prep i really need your
prep
it's breaking us down
he remembered every fourth word that's
good enough look at that
um all right so yeah uh salmon july 15th
audible
sounds awesome i'm in do you have to
join audible
um i think i'm already a member but if
i'm not i'm [ __ ] joining for that i
believe you
do but i'm sure there's a trial it's
usually a 90-day trial try as much as
you want and then
[ __ ] in hey man you could keep making
[ __ ] like that i was just i did a
superman uh a
live tweet for dc tuesdays um i did one
last well this week that just passed on
tuesday
for uh the batmobile
documentary they did and the week before
that was a superman documentary look up
in the sky
that's cool and um in it i was talking
about you know on the documentary they
said you know superman had a radio show
for a while
and so i tweeted like hey could that
even work in this day and age like you
know [ __ ] superman radio show i would
totally do it
and it got like the most interaction
people like [ __ ] yeah can do it
um and there you go [ __ ] neil gaiman
must have been sitting there being like
just wait a minute and here's my big fat
sandman dick on audible
i will put that all over my face negan
chest and directly in my ears i can't
wait to listen to that sam and one of
the greatest
piece of art i've ever interacted with
in my life if you've not read
uh sandman give it a read kat dennings
is a pretty good choice for death now
that i think about it yeah no i think
she'll uh
good job i like her i i don't like him
here
i don't like two broke girls really like
i watched it was like not not feeling
this
but she's done enough [ __ ] beyond that
that i'm like oh you know what
[ __ ] yeah you co-sign [ __ ] yes
uh last bit of the most passionate i've
seen him be about anything on this show
[ __ ] yes [ __ ] yes cat dennings more cat
denning says mark bernard please
uh mark bernard running on the cat
dennings platform
you're going to give you 100 more kat
dennings than you ever had
dennings bernardin 1820. look you got my
[ __ ] vote
it could be with the other broke girl i
don't care who you pair up with
any broke girls i'm voting for you
uh last news story um this is the last
story of the night this is the last
story of the night you're ready to go to
bed [ __ ]
this is the last story of the night i
don't even think we could do q a cause
i'll probably fall asleep in the middle
of it so
this is it just in case you were like ah
we still got q and a ahead of us
you see any good question [ __ ]
i shouldn't have asked all right here's
your last question let's just be the end
last i mean not last question last story
last story
of the night mark were you an anne rice
reader ever
no but i did like the movie very much um
with tom cruise and and uh young brandon
brad pitt young brad pitt and
and uh spider spider man's girlfriend
i just reduced her to spider-man's
girlfriend like that [ __ ] walk of
fame tweet i feel like an [ __ ]
kirsten [ __ ] dunce bring it on
there you go well done
uh the n rice library the entirety of it
the rights have uh have been acquired by
hold on hold on um so that means you can
make like they only made one movie right
they made queen of the damned but not
with tom cruise or brown no no that was
starring aaliyah
that's right um all right so you know
this is a ripe
ip rich territory you turn this into any
number of [ __ ]
movies and or series i would lean more
towards series at this point
um let me see um
hmm netflix seems like an obvious too
obvious in the
answer so hbo
nope neither neither hulu
nope crackle
yes wow kids crackle's taking a [ __ ]
jump they're bringing anne rice
yeah playskool suddenly has a network
excuse me i'm going to pitch to crackle
[Laughter]
what uh i have not disney plus not
disney plus
uh plus fancy it up
disney blues disney plus um
[ __ ] my imagination is limited nah and
we said hbo so not hp on hbo not netflix
not crackle not hulu not hulu
amazon no cbs no
dc universe
[Laughter]
youtube no
quibby because holy [ __ ]
get your money fast dan rice
where amc
oh you know what smart
because walking dead is walking to a
close sooner or later it is and so they
have their zombies
now that they're doing vampires that you
know what that makes sense
i never would have guessed them in a
million years but that's that's a bona
fide good idea they'll get a lot of
mileage out of them those books correct
me from wrong
had massive fan bases huge they're all
you know [ __ ] 80 now
but like the people that read those
books like
she was like the you know [ __ ]
twilight lady of her time
indeed and there's a [ __ ] ton of books
um
they they the vampire chronicles itself
of which
the the interview the vampire was the
first right has 18 titles
vampires right interview of the vampire
and then was it queen of the damn
queen of the damned tale of the body
thief memnoch the devil the vampire
armand
pandora vittorio you're taking me back
to like the early 90s yes blood and gold
prince lestat prince lestat and the
realms of atlantis
and blood communion the tale of prince
lester god you would think she was
getting paid to write these books
the amount of them she did [ __ ] i just
do things as a hobby for free
but [ __ ] wow man she must be rich she's
not bad off i don't think
um 50 million copies she's like you know
what jk rowling can have her [ __ ] i did
that first
i was i was the first super rich lady
writer probably not even her jaclyn
suzanne or some sort of [ __ ]
yeah or like vc andrews or agatha
christie i mean
holy [ __ ] excellent call and [ __ ] but a
great poll with vc andrews
like flowers in the attic pedals in the
wind if there'd be thorns
deep cuts now i'm back in the 70s thank
you mark
i just want to keep going back further
and further want to go back in time just
like that new movie that they're doing
what are they doing time traveling that
was comparing it to end game they're
in-game and that [ __ ]
oh uh hold on i've already forgotten the
news
yes you're right back in time i've
forgotten my name um all right
but yes so according to variety who
reported this amc
holds the comprehensive rights for the
iep to de develop its own networks and
streaming
services they might have their own
[ __ ] vampire channel
oh well they got an amci yeah and they
got shutter which is under that age oh
that's true
oh that's something that could bolster
that company totally
wow we're seeing the future take shape
at amc i co-signed this but i think
that's a good guess
i don't know how much they paid for it
but like you you get a lot of fodder out
of that you create a lot of television
shows a lot of
loyalty from an audience and mark's
right it's like they did their zombies
now they're doing their
classy zombies now they're doing classy
vampires and not only do they have
vampires but
a part of this deal is the series that
she has called the mayfair witches
which i knew nothing about because i'm
said i could do witches
they could do witches as well suddenly
you're now in that crazy supernatural
you know what i'm hearing out of this
story once again you and me
ain't got nothing going on what the [ __ ]
man
there's always some story about how some
[ __ ] won at life and we're just
sitting here talking about it god damn
it got to go out and anne rice this [ __ ]
i got a universe ain't vampires but what
the [ __ ] man
but what if they were yeah yeah there
you go
you love jay and samba what if they were
bloodsuckers
um all right let's see if we got a
question man that's the end of the news
give it up for marketing yeah
news no more news no more news no good
news is good good news says gary
canoe jc you got a question that you
like all right uh owen nelson
if you both could take a classic damsel
in distress character and make a feature
film who would it be and what would be
about and his example was mary jane from
spider-man
so who do you kind of flip the script
flip the script with
lois lane son i'll go before him [ __ ]
him i'm gonna jump right in front of the
line
dude lois lane there you go what do i do
with her
i don't know you know i haven't really
given any thought i just got the
assignment for heaven sex but
um you know um
yeah i go lois lane probably the most
famous
woman in peril from media right like
she's always needing saving and
stuff um you know superman always maybe
she'll need save him with superman
always saving her
but that would be my story about her
she's like i don't need superman to save
me
i need superman because he inspires me
because hope
because i don't know if you know this
but this s doesn't mean superman it
means hope
on his planet yeah for her for him
so i planted tennessee yeah that's what
she's like
you know that's her arc is to teach him
that
how to read
that's an ass clark it's a stunning
[ __ ] take
on the man of steel illiterate like look
he's so big and beautiful and dumb as a
stump
let me teach this man how to read gotta
get smart i'm a writer i'm not gonna
hang out with some dummy
like you gotta use bigger words um yeah
lois lane i'd have an
adventure adventure with lois lane no
superpowers
and uh you know she's
she rescues her damn self hell yeah
which she did a lot too to be fair in
the comics she'd get herself in jams and
out of them
it wasn't always superman but [ __ ]
let me tell you this if you knew that
superman would
always [ __ ] come save you wouldn't
you start living risky
i'm surprised she wasn't shooting heroin
you know what i'm saying
i think you're [ __ ] flying at the
last minute no lois no more eight balls
lois i
knew you would save me who's your choice
um sleeping beauty oh do
tell yeah the ultimate victim the
ultimate victim i think uh
i think there's probably no you know is
that
same beauty or cinderella i walk with
you once upon a dream
[Music]
oh and you made fun of my bg's i know my
bad of course
i just resorted to cats um all right so
yes
steaming beauty um the the story as i
remember it goes
here's this woman who's in a sort of
glass box and if you open it up and you
kiss her she comes back to life
what if she's a zombie what if the glass
box was keeping
the contagion inside what if it was the
hermetically sealed way to keep a
[ __ ] kingdom you're [ __ ] scaring
me we're in the middle of a contagion
i know right and so what if prince
charming [ __ ] opens up this box
yes and uh and causes plays
[Music]
and he becomes the first zombie yeah
does she is she a zombie or does she
stay beautiful and i think she says
beautiful and fresh that's [ __ ] dope
this is good hey write this down
she's asymptomatic she's an asymptomatic
carrier
shut the [ __ ] up copyright mark bernard
and
to a lesser degree kevin smith and maybe
the person that asked the question
this is sellable it's a vulnerable idea
i know i should stop talking about it
right yeah shut up
but then what if like anyway his answer
is [ __ ] cinderella moving on
[Laughter]
you didn't see her anything that's a
good idea man
i want to keep playing but shut up stop
talking don't give away the gold for
free
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah zooms are easy now you
can [ __ ] pitch nine times a day
you should just be coming up with silly
ideas and being like next caller
hey how you doing talking douche bag
they're like sold
we got this does that have a moral like
yeah don't
douche regularly i don't know i'm not
sure what the moral is we'll work on
that later
yeah i've never really understood that
douchebag is a threat it seems like it's
a cleansing agent
yeah when somebody's like you're a
[ __ ] douchebag like well of course i
am thank you that means i get a lot of
[ __ ] thank you very much
and i make it sparkle
i make it sparkle um wait a second
i mean [ __ ] if mason gills doesn't call
back
that's a writer in a hell of a line
people in the same way
we remembered [ __ ] like now and
forever cats the winter garden theater
every [ __ ] child who would [ __ ]
remember
like let's make that [ __ ] sparkle mass
and guilt
yeah can we get james earl jones make it
sparkle
making [ __ ] sparkle we don't have to
say [ __ ] it's a commercial they'll
never let us say but there's a bunch of
cats though
make angelica
um i like yours man he had a better
answer
that's good but that's a legit like good
idea we'll keep that yeah [ __ ] try to
sell that
all right give us another one so we can
make people forget
uh let's see colin wants to know if you
were making a new star wars holiday
special
which modern comedians and musical
guests would you cast
in place of art carney b arthur
jefferson starship
okay number one legit amazing question
well played
yeah you need to have a div whatever you
do in life you're getting underpaid you
need to be out here with us
creative people because that's [ __ ]
good man
uh what was it again what what which
comedians and musical acts would we put
in our
who would be my art current first let me
start with b arthur who's my current day
b
arthur tiffany haddish nice thank you i
mean this is christmas special right
they got money it's on disney plus
it's on the plus thank you canal plus
disney
plus tiffany haddish is my barmaid
uh who runs the cantina um let's see
art carney what was his role in the
christmas special
i don't know oh jc nobody can
watch that front to back it's like you
watch it for the commercials
i haven't remember who reacted did he
talk to lumpy he came to the house right
and talked to chewie's grandfather or
chewie's dad lumpy you remember
far too much plot was he the guy who had
like six arms
no art carney's guy he talks like this
he's you know he was [ __ ] norton on
the honeymooners and [ __ ]
too old for you um all right so who
would be my art
carney art carney was a legendary tv
figure i mean my tiffany haddish isn't
directly
a be arthur correlation so why am i even
trying to
[ __ ] figure out who my modern day art
carney is let's just think about
older we need an older actor there oh
jeremy irons is my art kearney right
hilarious
jeremy irons he's can be funny he's very
funny
no idea
he um funny yes he was funny in the
watchmen and we all live in the watchmen
now
because they just announced in
california it is illegal
not to wear a mask indeed we live
in my childhood dream it's a world of
superheroes everyone's wearing masks
now when they say face mask i was
thinking i'd say they're probably
talking this [ __ ] but what if i wear a
full
spiderman face mask i think you're fine
but am i breaking the law
no can i walk into a bank or will they
be like hitting buttons and [ __ ] like
that
i think we have to sort of relax the the
standards of security guards and banks
given that everybody's wearing a mask
that's true we live in a world of mass
yeah
say again
while you're in line they vet you the
rest of the time trying to figure out
wow one guard can take you if only one
of you is the robber
[ __ ] andrew doing some suspicious
research into this subject
he's like casing the joint unless
they're like
why that doesn't work at the bank that's
he knows an awful lot about the
situation
i would like to make a withdrawal
out of your monies wait where were we
going to found out what andrew does when
he's not doing this [ __ ] show
no wonder he's a [ __ ] rich dilite man
he's [ __ ] robbing banks left and
right
he's [ __ ] el zorro over there yeah
one cents two pence three pets a peso
everyone for zorro stand up and say so
that is awesome what was that from zero
the gay blade have you never seen
zombies
i did back in the day with uh what's the
name uh
yeah uh george hamilton george hamilton
i was gonna say brenda vaccaro yes
i uh i that was my first zoro movie that
i ever saw was zoro the gay blade
and loved it to [ __ ] death and do the
chants again it's one pens two pens
three pants a peso
everyone for zorro stand up and say so
that's when
zorro's uh identical twin brother bunny
wigglesworth
has to come in cause zorro broke his
ankle and can't go out and do a bunch of
crime fighting and so he calls on his
gay cousin bunny
very progressive movie yes and no
this is like 1981. true and uh oh you
mean the
the gay blade is not played with respect
not so much
um but he has like a bunch of like very
flamboyantly colored
outfits with little balls on the end of
his hat it's like he's wearing pink and
reds and baby blues
and i still love that movie and it's got
great [ __ ] sword fighting and george
hamilton is legit good
he's wonderful did you see and i saw him
recently in a documentary
it was the documentary about natalie
wood that was on hbo
he [ __ ] looks amazing i mean he
always aged well but he's still aging
well
turns out if you bake a dude that much
everything gets shiny and well preserved
i guess
he's kept like one of them shrunken head
apples he looks great
he's preserved forever um all right wait
wait anyway
what was the question again oh yeah who
were casting yes
so who is my i said jeremy irons and
then
who else do i got to cast jefferson's
starship weezer
hands down weezer's my band don't you
want to watch my star wars christmas
special
call me kathy kennedy disney plus i'm
here
i'm free we've got a place we can shoot
it
set right here halfway home can you see
tiffany haddish right here
i can now my journey yes
all right uh i need a female uh i need a
b
arthur type i need a b arthur type to
sing in the bar
um it's a great she's gonna be a
singer too right well then b arthur
wasn't yeah i was gonna say
look we're playing fast and loose with
the oldest here totally
she might have won like a tony or two
but not for her she kind of talked her
song through
it wasn't singing so much as i am
singing
this is a song my friends uh
julie louis dreyfus wow nice pull
thank you nice paul um are carney
he's dead you gotta pick somebody else i
gotta i gotta pick somebody alive
um i kinda i kinda all right
[ __ ] it uh yeah pat and oswalt
nice nice and as for the musical act
yeah boys to men
boys to men how could i not do boys to
men they're getting a lot of work lately
they were insane they really are
they were in that seth rogen movie
weren't they um they were
yes and then something else they were
involved in some
they did it they did oh there's an snl
on mother's day right it's in the air
it's in the air there's always to manage
your band what are they saying
i think you just want [ __ ] motown
philly back again like because why would
you not
play the [ __ ] hits what was their
what was their ballad
i made love to you like you
want me to and i'll hold you tight
did they also do this is probably not
them but did they do uh
it's so hard to
say goodbye i think so i think so
yesterday how could
i sing
but that's how you end the star wars
special
[Laughter]
uh wait so if you're doing it like but
you know you can't do princess leia and
stuff you'd have to do with the new
generation of star wars
heroes so daisy ridley would have to
sing us out
with the you know [ __ ] life day song
like carrie did
yes sadly or you have oscar isaac do it
who was in a sky ska band back in the
day
oscar isaac is this and dance like a
[ __ ]
yeah oscar isaac can cut a rug i
guarantee you he'd be more into it than
carrie was with a shot that special man
i think you get john boyega and and
[ __ ] oscar isaac
and daisy ridley on there they won't
stop dancing and
you get a little bb-8 in there and [ __ ]
little baboo frick
rock on bobby's just rolling joints in
the corner um you know what they're
never
going to let us do make this
maybe maybe you know who's going to do
it dave filoni
because they'll they'll let him do
anything now and why wouldn't you
kathy i got an idea dave give us
what we all want you love george we know
it
i know george hated the christmas
special but still give us a new one
that'd be such a great surprise for
christmas man a christmas special
that'd be so nice these
the best second best gift since baby
yoda uh all right
one more because those are good but you
better pick one that's
equally as good if not better yes
um if uh suppose you're quarantined
who asked strange reason who asked oh
charlie jones hey charles charlie jones
stop with one more jones i love your
work one marvel
and dc character who do you pick what am
i doing
you get one marvel and one dc character
to be quarantined with who do you pick
doctor strange because he'll be like
you're you're this is the day you die or
just he just keeps on holding my finger
and you have to guess yeah like what
does that mean he's like
smell it smell it yeah i was like
that's why i'd love to be quarantined
with him when you held up that [ __ ]
thing
what did you really mean never mind
[ __ ] marcus and mcfeely and [ __ ]
i want to know what you thought and he
was like
shut up um doctor strange is my marvel
choice
who's my uh good weed what doctor
strange will have good weed
no kid and if he didn't he could make it
out of nowhere
he'd have to draw from some of the dark
you know magic from [ __ ]
some of the drama i have a deal for you
oh my god we'd be stuck forever
over and over dormammu
i come to bargain um all right and on
the dc side
um i'm to say swamp thing because of the
weed
a little bit and beyond the weed he has
the tubers that grow on his body
remember you could eat them and people
were like whoa
and they saw the real world and through
colors and [ __ ] like that plus
you know plant so it's like constantly
you know he sucks in my carbon dioxide
he's giving me oxygen
nah and you can eat him because you're a
vegan
i wouldn't do that he's my friend i'd
get on his back he'd carry me around
like a little kid
because he's really strong he'd go
anywhere too man you could be like
can you go pick us up some food at
crossroads and be like sure
and his body turns into this dried husk
and two seconds later she
was just split and he rebuilds his
[ __ ] body
he's got food for you nice yeah um swamp
thing
and doctor strange dr strange i was
almost going to go doctor strange and dr
fate but [ __ ] getting all mystical and
[ __ ] like that
and whatnot are you quarantining at uh
at the
sanctum sanctorum no [ __ ] that my house
i don't want to quarantine somebody
else's house i know where all my [ __ ] is
and whatnot
then i can just if i don't want to hang
out with them anymore i just go to my
room
but if i'm at the sanctum sanctorum and
he wants to hang out and i'm like oh my
god i just want to go [ __ ]
check my email and look at twitter and
[ __ ] then i got to make excuses so you'd
rather be
anti-social in your own space and it's
somebody else's space i mean how much
time can you spend with doctor strange
you know
but you chose him dude i know but you
know i chose my wife too
she's not watching so that joke can play
excellent um all right who are your two
um number one great question yes well
done
chuck jones very creative um dc
character yes um morpheus
oh right on because you're gonna have
some pleasant dreams
you're gonna sleep like a [ __ ]
house you can sleep the whole quarantine
and i'll be everywhere and anywhere and
tell me a story dream
and having like vivid [ __ ] dreams and
when you finally wake up you can [ __ ]
put them to work and you're writing and
stuff like that [ __ ] yeah that's a good
choice i'd be like hey man knock me out
until this is all over and it'd be like
oh my god you're going to go to the land
of cats
not you know the jellicles the land of
no the actual yeah
would be the prince of cats so that is
your dc that's my decent choice
[ __ ] good poll um i think
i think kingpin kingpin
yeah wilson fist wilson [ __ ] fish
show's over ladies and gentlemen
a villain why because he will have the
most secure place to be in quarantine
like that [ __ ] penthouse is
like fort knox like nobody's getting in
nobody's getting out
well daredevil got in and out in love
and war he got all the way up to the top
one time i mean that's all you need
but let's pretend look at matt murdock
gets in there and [ __ ] lets that
billy clue
like billy plus billy club loose
ping ping ping hits his bald [ __ ]
head it's over
peter parker can't do what matt murdock
would do and has done to the [ __ ]
kingpin peter parker
kingpin was originally his villain and
stuff as we saw in the spider-verse
movie and [ __ ]
but him was just a little boy and even
when he grew up he's not going to take
out kingpin
matt murdock would have [ __ ] killed
the kingpin
many a [ __ ] time yeah like adam
really jumped out of my manager back
like [ __ ] you no
[ __ ] you because kingpin had it coming i
was like he's got a nice house
i'm sure it's pretty secure he's a fat
dude he's got lots of food
we'll be fine but he's also like running
that [ __ ] generator opening up
dimensional riffs trying to get his wife
and kid back
which kingpin do we have do i get to
choose my kingpin yeah which one you're
picking
not the one
[Laughter]
good choice transdimensional riffs and
[ __ ] excellent choice excellent choices
like i'm a crime boss not as ambitious
we're quarantining it's all good all the
sausage you could want
excellent uh bizarre pull though yes now
i'm going for the now between you and
[ __ ] andrew talking about robin banks
the tui has got the
you're mixed up with the bad guys i'm
just saying you're like my idol is
kingpin because
him so smart and strong yeah i'm
basically choosing the dude with the
best house to quarantine in
less fair enough partner what i'm
getting out of this story is you'd
rather not quarantine your place
no no no all i want to do is quarantine
on my place i mean my place is fine but
a little too tight
and so i would much rather have like be
king in new york you have penthouse and
[ __ ] like right
or like ooh maybe so he is [ __ ]
temperamental mark
like [ __ ] kingpin like [ __ ] one
look yeah
i want to be holed up with a mobster
while the whole [ __ ] world falls
apart and [ __ ] like that
he's like we're losing money i [ __ ]
hey
someone's getting killed and you're
there let's open the economy
yeah the crime economy sounds familiar
um all right man to each their own mark
made the most bizarre choice of the
night
i really did inventive though creative
and stuff stick with it you know what
you got dreams so you could always put
good here let me help you out of your
[ __ ] hole mark yes please with
dream on your side you could just put
[ __ ] wilson fisk to sleep
and there you're enjoying the lap of
luxury without having to [ __ ] talk to
crazy ass wilson fisk right see and i
was also like trying to aim for a person
who lived by himself for the most part
like
the x-mansion would be pretty cool
except there's 58 [ __ ] children
running around oh and they're all
quarantined together and they're all
quarantined together same thing with the
avengers mansion yeah jarvis would be a
great roommate like he's a [ __ ]
butler he'd be really good at that [ __ ]
make me a savage jarvis excellent
but there's the rest of the [ __ ]
avengers there doing the dumbass
avengers [ __ ] and i think they would get
on my nerves
let me tell you something the house you
want to quarantine at is tony stark's
[ __ ]
house movie oh my god with the talking
house and all the views and [ __ ] like
that
i mean [ __ ] you'd be like what
quarantine
i'm great i choose to be here it's a
[ __ ] tuesday that's why i'm here
[Laughter]
those are three great questions man i
was ready to [ __ ] blow this popsicle
stand but i'm glad i stayed man that
[ __ ] made me happy
you know i would have been rather put
out if you just like [ __ ] i'm done
and yeah
i don't want to drop it because it will
really hurt um wow
we did it again and we this time with
feeling
ladies and gentlemen fun yeah good times
remember chris wood was on the show
eight hours ago great he was like
man uh thanks to our guest chris wood
for taking the time let's see who we get
next week right ooh
victor garba perhaps oh worried my heart
beats still
he's the gobbler beating heart man um
thanks uh to jc give a jc shot there
um well you got to put a shot on you
nope
there it is jc and you're staging a tiny
rebellion opens up this place lets us do
the show here at the cantina and stuff
as he plots world domination over there
thanks to andrew uh who's in the other
room and [ __ ]
uh that he really has to account for the
whole audience
he really does i gauge how we do based
on whether or not andrew is laughing
so and it's a high bar for him pretty
high [ __ ]
[ __ ] laugh dude out here he don't
give it out for free and [ __ ] you got to
earn it with andrew
um thanks the boys for making the time
so that me and this man can come in
and [ __ ] talk about the [ __ ] that
makes us happy and whatnot indeed
now we go back to our horrible lives no
now we go back to our wonderful families
and wait
one full week before we get to do this
again who will be our guest
give us suggestions um who do you know
that you can come
give us their numbers as well that would
be a help
you should talk to my girlfriend she's
really smart okay
you got it phil yeah i'm done totally
talking to you let's bring her in
uh thanks for being here ladies and
gentlemen there is no show without the
man standing to my left give it up
for the marvelous mr mark bernard ladies
and gentlemen thank you captain smith
thanks my name don't wear it out and
that
is fat man beyond for this week man i'm
kevin smith
i'm mark bernard tune in next week same
fat time same [ __ ] fat
channel smodcast.com or you calm
slash kevin smith i went for the good of
all cree
i went cage on that one yeah it was
pretty sweet hard cage
you